so we're playing white against weak move
wake so we're going to play very
aggressively
we still haven't had the chance to play
a legitimate danish gambit
let's hope that we ah
still know the finished game but he goes
knight c6 okay
[Music]
so what do we do in this position
we've already been in this situation
before and the
instinct though that a lot of people
have here is to play d5 and i've
previously explained why that's not my
favorite move
um and the short reason is that it
closes down the center knight f3
transposes into a scotch
but i think the best move is actually
just to take the pawn
right why well first of all this opens
up the center
second of all this knight on e5 is
actually not very well placed
it's very susceptible to a bunch of
different attacking moves
one of which is f4 but f4 isn't the best
move it's a very common type of
instinct again to simply attack the
knight thank you chester but it's not
the best
because f4 is very weakening it weakens
the king
and it uh doesn't allow the bishop to
develop naturally so let's develop very
flexibly
um that knight is in the center but it
has no support so we have a couple of
ways to go about this
let's start with the most flexible move
let's develop a piece
that we know we want to develop anyway
we know we'll develop this piece
eventually
which piece am i talking about here
these are kind of complicated concepts
that relate to development but they're
very important
yeah so it's knight c3 yeah
because knight f3 is already quite
committal right we offer the trade of
knights we don't know if we want to do
that yet
okay now the situation has changed the
movement f6
has actually informed us about what we
want to do next thank you aliki potato
believe it or not a move that previously
was very weakening
is now super good now the issue with
black's
is that he's developed his two knights
without moving out any pawns and when
that happens the reason you move pawns
out
is not only to open up your pieces it's
also
to give that exoskeleton to your
position when all you do is develop
pieces without pawns
those pieces become unstable and those
pieces can be attacked by pawns and i'm
sure that a lot of you guys
have seen instances of what we're about
to do many times we go
f4 but isn't this move weakening well it
still is
a little bit weakening but now it's
associated with a very strong follow-up
and that is e5
sending this knight back to g8 and it is
definitely worth it
uh worth a little weakening and also we
occupy a lot of the center
does that make sense so
he has to go knight g8 losing a ton of
tempe
then we bring our knight out and his
position looks very very grim he's not
lost or anything
yawn 42 thank you for gifting to house
party thank you guys i really appreciate
it
okay so how will i try to castle
queenside i don't know yet
um it depends on how he plays this his
best move would be
this guy is playing pretty well now
here's another tip for you guys
um i think people sometimes when
you have an initiative right or you have
a development advantage
naturally people try to avoid the end
game but there are situations
where going into an end game does not
necessarily lessen your initiative
or the chances that you're going to
attack the king there are situations
where
um where end games are actually
just a natural follow-up to how you're
playing the fact that you're trading
queens
doesn't necessarily mean that you no
longer have any attacking potential we
have a lot of pieces that aren't the
queen
so this is a great example of that thank
you herba gurba
we can make a development move that does
allow
a queen trade but in the event of that
queen trade um
he would have lost his castling rights
and his king would have been a sitting
duck instead he goes bishop d7
okay so we're actually just going to
castle
because the king will still have a nice
pawn shell the fact that we put
the fact that we move the f pawn doesn't
make this king particularly unsafe
right and he's doing us a big favor by
opening up that f
file thank you very much now his king is
going to be in trouble he gives us a
check
and it appears that actually black will
develop his pieces before we do
but that doesn't matter because the f
file is now open
and his development is very haphazard
super passive
that pawn on f7 is going to be the
vehicle through which we
developed a very quick attack against
this king
i hope this makes sense so far i know
there's a lot of specific questions
about
what we're doing here and i'll answer
most of those after the game
he goes knight g7 yeah this guy is
definitely
definitely good now
when we reach these types of situations
we need to be super careful about how we
go about this
knight g5 is the most tempting move but
when you make a move like night g5 we
all have to ask ourselves
what is this leave behind how does that
change the position
and remember that you do have an
isolated pawn here let's not forget that
so what does knight g5 allow what nasty
response
and light is still good there but it's
not you know i don't think there's a
need to calculate this black can play
knight takes e5
and that knight defends the f7 pawn
so we have to be very methodical about
how we're actually approaching
this question um and instead of knight
g5 we can look around the board and say
well what development moves can we make
what
active moves can we play first thing
that my
i but like my mind's eye sees is this
bishop on c5 right
and bishop on c5 is undefended let's
start with the move 94 centralizing the
knight
and attacking the bishop i think that's
a good starting point
so don't overthink these kinds of moves
i'm not like
coming up with some crazy idea i'm just
improving the position of my pieces
this is probably not even the best move
right i'm not even
searching too hard for the quote-unquote
best but i'm just trying to find a good
way to continue the initiative there's
many good moves here
all right then we're going to follow up
probably by developing this bishops best
score for the bishop is very clearly g5
pinning the knight yeah even bishop h6
would be interesting but
we okay so immediately he blunders
the knight knight takes c5
okay guys there's nobody
should ever be sending anybody hate
messages
and uh that goes without saying it's not
welcome in this community
yeah i mean if anybody gets those
messages that's just not right
there's trolls but um
yeah so bishop bishop back to c4
and we're basically winning
okay so yeah
uh gave her a moment i that that's a
great question
why didn't we take the queen immediately
um and that relates
to the notion of whether it is a good
idea to trade
when you're up material it is a super
contentious question because there's a
lot of
i would almost say contradictory
opinions
on on this question right of whether
you're trading and
i always say the sort of the same thing
i think that a lot of coaches and chess
content creators
over emphasize the notion that you
should trade when you're up material
trading when you're a material is not
inherently a good thing it usually is a
good thing
to simplify because when you're up a
rook
um winning a position where you have a
rook against a king is usually going to
be easier
than winning a position when there's a
bunch of other pieces on the board
that's self-evident
but a lot of players turn this into i
have to simplify when i'm up material
and it's very easy i see a lot of
blunders that come from ignoring other
features of the position
in the hopes of simplifying let's defend
upon
and i also see a lot of beginners
particularly be blind
to attacking opportunities um
again because they're trying to simplify
so
try to evaluate it on a case-by-case
basis
a lot of the time if you have a good
opportunity to simplify
you should go for it but at the same
time if you feel like you can go for
checkmate
that is often a far more effective way
to end the game
fast okay so here for example
you know i have a trade i have an
opportunity to trade rooks yeah
why not okay we're giving up the d file
that's not a big deal though it's an end
game particularly because we can take
another pawn the same goes for that
advice i shared which is that
um which is that you shouldn't take too
many extra pawns when you're already up
a bunch of pieces
that should also be taken in its proper
context if there are
free pawns that you can take without any
consequences then
absolutely you should take more stuff
okay so again now we're simplifying
yeah if you're someone who crafted any
kind of
eightfold message you should be very
much
ashamed of yourself
and yeah
that's that okay so let's go here
then we're gonna move the bishop back
and then we're gonna win this pawn and
the game is over we're up a piece
these kinds of end games the general
conversion process to identify a past
pawn
and promote it what passpon should we
identify and how should we go about
promoting it
not the hardest question i've ever asked
you guys
because particularly in light of his
last move
all right e7 is correct
e7 is correct
digital cosmos he's a little bit
underrated but but you know we want a
pretty convincing game
when the game is over notice that bishop
a4 would stop the bomb but this knight
on c5
is defending that square and here is oh
no he doesn't resign
thank you for the 300 chest down
okay
yeah he was playing he was playing fine
although he was already in pretty big
trouble
at that point okay
you resign now exactly okay we make a
queen he doesn't resign
now the most efficient mate is to bring
this bishop down to d3
which forces him to weaken his king even
further then we're gonna mop up this
pawn
swoop in with the bishop and checkmate
him on h7
actually there is an even faster mate
than bishop takes g6 could somebody
find it what is the fastest mate 6 400
wow and dikaya thanks for being patient
all
happy to get a game in with you before
we analyze yeah knight e6 and queen g7
goodbye
oh he's got to check i missed that
doesn't really matter
and he has another check so i guess he
can prolong it for two more moves okay
um dakaio down for down for a game
if you're still up
yeah you can challenge me on the all my
lands account
yeah he found the best move knight f2
a hillbilly attack from its most famous
specialists
all right in the meantime we can start
analyzing so
okay yeah even gm's tunnel vision no
totally that's a big big problem
so knight c6d takes c5 right so just to
respond to this notion that the knight
is in the center right
why let's make a general statement here
why is it even
good for a piece to be in the center
what is it about the center
that makes a piece good right or makes a
piece more likely to be good what's
what it has to do with square control
right a piece is in the center
mathematically speaking it just controls
more squares particularly in knight
but controlling squares is not an
inherently good thing right it's a good
thing because it generally makes the
piece more active but it
it you know when you're on move four
there aren't any weak squares right
square the weaknesses the position
hasn't yet been well defined
so it's a little bit less meaningful for
a piece to be in the center that's why
you'll see some beginners go 95 in a
position like this right
because you're taught to put your pieces
in the center but because your opponent
has a lot of resources to kick away
pieces
it's more important to develop quickly
rather than position your pieces in the
center
100 bits thank you absolutely the
destiny dodge thank you
now the other reason is that i can play
a move like knight f3 and i can
essentially offer a trade and if you
trade knights then you have moved this
night
one two three times
trading it for a night that's only moved
once
that way you lose two moves that's not a
good thing right and this queen is kind
of nicely placed on f3
okay so i hope that makes sense knight
c3
knight f6 now we play f4 and e5 now
though this knight is a sitting duck
knight g8 and time your questions to
where we are in the game so if you have
a question about this position this is
where you should ask it
d6 that's correct he's breaking into our
pawns
and um here's a good question for you
guys
if he would have played bishop before
should we go bishop d2 is it a good idea
to go bishop d2 and remove the pen
what do you guys think can we do we
should do a poll on this actually this
is a pretty important concept
so some of you saying yes
some of you saying no the answer to this
is i'll give you guys a second to think
about this moment
the answer is no so
there's two reasons and not because it
blocks the queen
not because it blocks the queen that's
not the main reason at least
so remember from the first speed run
okay let me
explain it step by step it's important
first of all pins are naturally
unpleasant
but there are two categories of pins one
of them is generally more dangerous than
the other
a pinned piece that is protected by a
pawn
that pin is generally generally going to
be less dangerous and urgent
than a pin in which the pinned piece i
call this the penny
the king is the penny the blue piece and
the knight is the pinned piece
when the pin piece is protected by a
pawn that piece is usually
in no immediate danger unless there is
the threat of like black getting a pawn
to d4
so that's something that's sort of
beside the point here but that
lessens the urgency of this pin i hope
that makes sense so far
the second thing is i've always spoken
about how
pawn structure is a little bit less
significant than most other things like
peace placement
particularly when you're a beginner so
think of it this way what does black
give up what concessions does black make
if he takes the knight let's say we go
bishop c4
and black takes the knight well first of
all black's put you know black's made
two moves with the bishop
trading it for a piece that's only moved
once he's lost the tempo
second of all white or black has given
this bishop
a very nice square who what square am i
talking about here
what square am i talking about here
yeah and one of the problems with this
trade is baked into the cake for black
if uh white brings the bishop to a3
guess what black has given up his dark
squared bishop he's given y the two
bishop advantage
black will almost never be able to play
the d6 to play d6
which is a crucial move that liberates
his position black is
essentially dominated here completely
right
and the last thing is from a pretty
simple perspective black is now
um very seriously just underdeveloped
and after knight g7 why can just go
after him knight g5 and queen h5 and the
game is essentially over
right so the last thing i'll say
is that doubled pawns and pawn structure
deficiency is generally going to be the
most dangerous when it occurs near your
king if we were talking here about
something on the king's side
and why did the king on the king's side
okay that's something you should attend
to more carefully
if it's a pawn structure deficiency on
the opposite flank from where you castle
it's not always necessary to make a very
passive move and bishop d2 is a passive
mode right
that's not the key developing we would
much rather develop this bishop first
um so you just don't want to go out of
your way like that to get rid of the pen
it also isn't necessary
to encourage bishop c3 this is also
overstepping and particularly because
you no longer have access to a3 right
but the middle ground here is just to
ignore it and let your opponent do this
now am i implying that it's always a
good idea to allow
a move like bishop takes e3 no sometimes
you know you do want to deal with the
pin sometimes you don't want to ruin
your pawn structure
but a lot of the time you should not be
inherently concerned about your pawns
being doubled
all right i does that logic make sense
anybody have questions about
how i explain this i mean hopefully it
makes sense
why you're not too afraid the reason
people are afraid of this is often
because of the visual like
oh you know look at those double points
they look horrible but
um they're often not
okay great i think it's an important
point
all right so d6 bishop b5 now if you had
taken d
e we would have taken on d a now this is
already an exception to the rule
here what would be a good move for white
yeah the c6 knight being immobilized is
kind of good
so here for example taking is something
i would consider now first of all we
could play just f takes e5 and that
would be perfectly good
but this is a pretty good alternative
because after knight takes e5 it
centralizes the knight forking the pawns
but this is less to do with the fact
that we double black's pawns and more to
do with the specific property of the
position right the fact that we have a
nice 995.
um so in any case well waiting
i mean you have to recapture the pawn
so in any case that would be really good
he goes bishop b sound we castle
takes takes yeah and here
again if we had got knight g5 we would
have allowed knight takes c5
um and that simultaneously defends the
f-pawn
so that's why we decided to centralize
the knight and attack the bishop and now
had he moved the bishop back
bishop g5 would have been an incredibly
good move
just um pinning the knight and after
castles
i think that white has a crushing
tactical move
and in honor of the plebs maybe one of
you guys can try to find
this tactical idea stinnymek tier one
thank you
how do i even know to look for this well
we're we have developed
all of our pieces and just look at the
disparity in peace activity right
white's got both of his bishops just
slicing down black's position the knight
is centralized
we have a pawn on e5 that clamps down
blacks because we have all of these
positional advantages
and oftentimes when that has reached its
apex you need to start looking for ways
to transform it
and the move is knight f6 check this
forks the king and the bishop so
black is compelled to take this is a
great example of where we wouldn't want
to make a move just because it sets a
threat
what recapture do you guys think is best
between those two
it's actually so it's actually the
bishop
right and the reason why is that this
keeps the knight immobilized it pins the
knight
and taking with the pawn would have
allowed black to play knight g6 bringing
the knight in
to the defense but by taking with the
bishop we set up the same lobster pincer
mate theme we will want the queen
to end up on g7 there's nothing that
black can do to stop it
so much so that let's say black on pins
himself
a very good move quiet but deadly
would be bringing the queen up to d2 or
to c1 threatening
uh queen h6 or queen g5 depending on
where black puts the knight
the game is over that's it there's
nothing the black can do about this
this just illustrates how you know peace
placement is so important you're down a
piece
you're not not even really feeling it
knight g5 is good too yeah knight g5 and
queen h5 is also fine
all right for sure it's a force to me
yeah so
the computer evaluation after a knight
f6 jack is plus five
black has slightly more resilient
methods of defending but by and large
this is just completely lost
okay so this is
basically crushing you place bishop f5
and after taking on c5
right um we don't really we aren't
really afraid of black not trading
queens because that would have given us
yeah i would have encouraged this this
would have actually accelerated black's
defeat
so does this make sense does anybody
have
questions on any of these moves i mean
the rest is very obvious i mean we just
played
normal development moves and one quickly
the rest is obvious
okay
[Music]
you